hello
can you hear me
help me i'm stuck
hello
hello
anyone
iron fist alexander a living jar who has
set out on a journey away from his
comfortable hidden away home of jarburg
to venture the world and become a mighty
warrior living jars are brought to life
by human flesh and blood they are rather
kinly folk which just means that they're
warm-hearted and gentle in nature their
description says that they were perhaps
made to be better than their innards
their fragments command a high price due
to their magical power locked within
this leaves the living jars unfortunate
targets for poachers we can learn more
about these poachers from our little pot
boy jar barn do you know what a poacher
is cuz
they hunt us
smash us
and then take us away
this village is kept secret
so
i think we're safe here
but you should be careful if you ever
meet one of them cause
i hope uncle alexander beats small up
first these poachers are the perfumers
that we can see spread around the lands
between
in times past the role of a perfumer was
much respected a blessed role in the
eyes of the many but after entering the
battlefields of the shattering they
performed no such role creating their
aromatics for poisons and explosives
eventually they became deprived and used
their own spices and potions to alter
their own body and mind they seem to
want the power of the shards of magic
within the living jars and have started
a slow descent into their own
self-destruction another being that
seems to hunt down the living jars are
the urgery avatars that we can see
surrounded by smash jars under many of
the minor urge trees the staff that they
wield tells us that the avatars emerged
in the wake of the elden ring shattering
and were determined to protect the
withering herd tree's offspring they
likely smash these living jars that are
filled with the flesh of the many of
fallen warriors who need to be returned
to the earth tree which helps feed the
minor urgeries and helps keep them from
dying however some of these jars decide
to fight back against these poachers
just like alexander who wants to become
a great warrior alexander intends to
take part in the radon festival to fight
against a legendary demigod to further
test his abilities in battle before he
leaves he rewards you with exalted flesh
for helping him out of this peculiar
random hole that he was stuck in exalted
flesh is considered a delicacy in the
badlands an invigorating meal that was
for the exclusive benefit of those who
they deem as heroes i believe this
reward that he actually gives us more
than once tells us more of what
alexander truly wants to be he wants to
be like us a tarnished warrior he has
the flesh of the fallen within his jar
and the flesh of those who once had the
sight of grace which is why i believe we
can find alexander in these holes
usually the sights of grace and the
sending gates are only meant for the
tarnished or those who still have or
once had the sight of grace within them
so it is possible that he has the
ability to travel as we do however since
it's just the flesh of grace mixed
randomly within his jar it obviously
doesn't go well every time he tries to
teleport and i'm sorry i just have to
say this but i have a hard time
believing that from software didn't
purposely make his dialogue somewhat
suggestive at times good gosh
stop please
that's my face this will have me as
slippery as a toad give me a good smack
from behind with something nice and big
oh yes now this may not be the case for
everybody but from what i've seen many
players actually miss this interaction
with alexander and caled within the gale
tunnel before you meet him again at the
radon festival this conversation with
alexander is one of the rare funny
moments in elden ring in fact i can't
even think of another moment that was as
light-hearted as this
according to my calculations
passing through this road should lead us
to the caled wilds
but
however you slice it it seems we've
reached a dead end
i'm sorry to have raised your hopes it
seems my calculations must have been off
oh
the esteemed warrior
where did you spring from
this was supposed to be a dead end i'm
sure of it what's going on here
a door from thin air
well
stranger things happen at sea or so i'm
told but
onward
to the caled wilds
ah
that dead end had me rather stumped
further into this conversation with
alexander he tells us more about his
purpose as a warrior jar
many great warriors reside within me
ever dreaming of becoming a great
champion it's my destiny
and the reason for which i quest
it is my ordeal you could say
to test myself to better myself
to fell ever greater foes
and then
one day we'll be a single great champion
the greatest of them all
what do you think eh
how do you rate my chances
he doesn't sound too confident at the
end here but that doesn't stop alexander
we can meet him next waiting inside red
main castle to fight against radon
himself full of excitement and
confidence once again to think
i could face a great champion of the
shattering
a demigod in the flesh
oh god
in truth i quiver at the thought such is
his frightful repute
but
the fear simply assures me the ordeal is
worth undertaking
be sure to get a good vantage my friend
i
iron fist alexander
do hereby vow to unflinchingly brave
this ordeal and alexander does exactly
that he braves this test of combat
against the strongest demigod in the
lands between and helps us in this
battle along with many other summonable
characters after we defeat radon and
watch the stars resume their movement
once again we can find alexander
scraping up the flesh of fallen warriors
that can be found all around this area
from the battle between radon melania
and their two opposing armies but along
with alexander's jar his confidence
seems to be cracked along with it oh
it was a battle marvelously fought
you are well and truly a champion friend
i on the other hand
am nothing but a croc
one hit was all it took to crack me and
for my insides to come spilling out
after that i
my
head like a coward
and as such
i can hardly stand to face one such as
you
after this we can find alexander stuck
yet again in another hole after we lube
our jar friend up and smack him hard
with something nice and big as he seems
to enjoy we can learn more about why
he's here yes indeed
i too have a home
though it is one to which i vowed not to
return
so
i thought i might look out from atop the
cliff
but as i drew closer and closer
pow
wouldn't you know it
i was perfectly stuck in that blasted
hole i can feel the warriors inside
admonishing me for my mortise
to walk the path of champions one cannot
cleave to the past
i'm headed to the fiery mount in the
north
i can strengthen myself there without
fear of cracking this vessel
i will forge myself anew in its flames
and as alexander usually is he's being
very literal about forging himself anew
in the flames of the mountain as he
bakes himself in the fire he gives us a
gift a jar helmet that alexander made
himself just for you the description of
the jar reads made with pride by iron
fist alexander in a uniquely jar-like
gesture of friendship if you really
think about it how many true friendships
do we really have on our journey through
the lands between at this point
alexander is a bit jealous of our power
we are the one who truly defeated radon
in battle while apparently alexander
cracked his jar and hid away but that
doesn't alter his resilience in fact
you motivate him to become stronger to
train harder and to just be a better
version of himself it sounds like we're
alexander's rival but just as it is in
his nature it's a friendly rivalry he's
happy about our accomplishments and
celebrates with us the further we
progress through our journey he is truly
our friend the next time we see
alexander is when we can summon him for
the fire giant fighting along with us to
defeat greater foes and become stronger
as a result you'll notice in this fight
that alexander is definitely no pushover
against the fire giant he really holds
his own and you can tell that he's
really becoming much stronger from his
training in an attempt to catch up with
our own strength when we meet him in
pharah missoula he's impressed with how
strong we've truly become to this point
you're certainly a force to be reckoned
with eh
i doubt there's a single soul who could
have handled that giant other than you
it was practically a god
of course i count myself the great
alexander among many alexander has once
again lost his confidence and as he said
he sees himself as one of the many who
wouldn't be able to handle the fire
giant in battle and that our strength is
rivaling that of a god but as we've
learned up to this point alexander's
entire existence is based on the pursuit
of becoming the strongest throughout our
journey with him he has been witness to
all of the incredible warriors that we
have defeated demigods and gods alike
for alexander to truly reach his goal of
being the strongest he will have to
fight against us to test his true
strength he'll have to battle against
his friend
which means i've but one thing to ask of
you
would you kindly undertake my ordeal
i've been longing to fight a warrior as
accomplished as you he waits until we're
ready and then starts the battle that
will decide his destiny and hours from
this point forward i am the great jar
warrior iron fist alexander
lend me strength o warriors within
let us become one champion together but
our strength turned out to be too great
for alexander but he knew this from the
start just as he's always done he's
happy to see how strong we've become and
as a reward he gives us something that
we've already been getting from him
since the moment we met him the
unstoppable will to become stronger in
the face of great adversity instead of
taking flesh like all living jars do he
gives us his own to continue our journey
under our friend's legacy to the very
end
as i suspected
victory
was impossible
this vessel was found lacking
my thanks
i knew you were the stuff of champions
it was a marvelous battle
i implore you
take what i bequeath
from inside me
all vessels are destined to one day
break
but the great alexander
lived as a warrior to his last
[Music]
[Music]
it's me
i'm a warrior too
[Applause]